on vientapendre que il y av une famille
qui était remise à la rue là avait une
solution jusqu'à samedi qui repart à la
rue samedi dans la
journée é héberg che des particuliers
pas de
solution avec
enants on va chercher une solution on a
une cagnotte et pour lesberg le weekend
c'est vs
vite en fait on a bien pas arriver au
point il faudrait qu'il y ait un mort
dans la rue pour que l'État se bouge
pour débloquer des places quoi et et là
vous vous faites du mieux que vous
pouvez pour mettre à l'avri les enfants
mais c'est pas tenable sur le long terme
quoi on bricole avec des bout de
ficelles j'essaie d'avoir la la
banderole en entier bonjour je suis
Marie Charlotte Garin je suis député
écologiste de Lyon aujourd'hui on est
devant une école de ma circonscription
parce que dans cette école dorment des
enfants qui dorment à la rue en temps
normal on se réunit pour alerter le
gouvernement sur le fait qu'on a besoin
de plus de place d'hébergement d'urgence
pour qu'on ait plus 2822 enfants qui
dorment dehors dans notre
pays 1 € sil vous plaît merci c'est
lequel ton gâteau que tu as faiti cel on
a pris de part ben je crois que tu vois
je vais goûter ton gâteau s'il en reste
cela devient une habitude pour
mariecharlotte gara quand la députée
arrive dans sa circonscription direction
l'école où des gûtés solidaires
s'organisent il y a plein de parents
mobilisés il y a des non parents qui
sont là ce soir
c'est bien les parents d'élèves ont
appris que trois enfants de l'école
dormaient dans la rue alors une
solidarité s'installe pour les aider si
par exemple on est en galère ce weekend
on sait qu'on a cette ce matelas cette
respiration pour pouvoir leur les loger
à l'hôtel quoi ce weekend mais ce sera
pas tous les weekends de l'année ça
suffira jamais ce soir-là 360 € auront
été récolté une cagnotte utile car le
numéro du Samu social est saturé parler
dem les familles elles te disent aussi
elles appellent tous les jours les
familles le 115 ell l'appell tous les
jours tous les jours bah là les chiffres
sont assez catastrophiques sur le 115 le
taux de réponse enfin en fait c'est pas
le taux de réponse c'est le taux de
solution trouvé et bah en fait sur 1600
1700 appels je crois la semaine du 2 au
8 octobre tu en as 1200 qui sont sans
solution et en fait c'est le cas tous
les jours et nous à côté de ça en tant
que parlementaire on se sent hyper
impuissant parce qu'on se dit ça craque
de tous les côtés il y a tout monde qui
est à bout que ça soit vous en fait
aussi parents d'élèves qui occupé et qui
bouleversz vos vies de famille pour
faire marcher la solidarité locale que
ce soit la ville qui essae mais qui a
pas non plus toutes les compétences pour
le faire ou les travailleurs sociaux il
y a tout le monde qui craque et il y a
pas de moyens qui sont mis sur la table
pour des engorger le 115 le gouvernement
annonce la création de 500 postes
supplémentaires au Samu
social à Lyon 330 enfants passent leur
journée à l'école et leur nuit dans la
rue des enfants en grande majorité
étranger le plus souvent en situation
irrégulière en France même s'il n'a pas
de papier un mineur a le droit d'être
scolarisé il faut savoir que la question
de la crise de l'hébergement d'urgence
aujourd'hui en fait c'est le résultat de
deux crises parallèles qui sont dans le
pays d'un côté une crise de l'accueil
c'est-à-dire qu'on ncueille pas
correctement les gens dans notre pays et
de l'autre une crise du logement tout
court et donc là du coup on se retrouve
en fait à palier à l'urgence ces enfants
qui dorment à la rue quand on dit qu'il
faut crer des ébergement d'urgence on a
bien conscience qu'on vient pas résoudre
ni la crise de l'accueil ni la crise du
logement mais en attendant c'est ce
qu'il faut faireac la député a invité la
presse locale pour faire témoigner Anan
une maman de l'école qui il y a encore
quelques mois dormit dans la
rue cette algérienne a fui son pays avec
son fils aujourd'hui en classe de
CE2 comment tu t'es senti quand tu as
dormi dans la rou
difficile mais un peu froid on peut pas
manger on peut pas faire pi on peut pas
faire
caca on peut on peut pas faire les
devoirs je dormir à la
rue quelques mois et
après je dors dans l'école de mon fils
de mois presque presque de mois et quand
je dormis dors à la rue je peur moi et
mon fils parce que c'est
difficile depuis la rentrée Anan et
Nordine logent dans un hébergement
d'urgence il peuvent y rester jusqu'à
septembre
prochain dans le gymnase de l'école où
Anan et Nordine ont également dormi une
autre famille a trouvé refuge chaque
soir grâce à la mairie ses TR enfants de
9 ans 6 ans et 6 mois s'installent dans
un confort sommaire mariechlotte Garin a
décidé de dormir
avec mon pyjama
toilie la députée est venue avec son sac
à dos et s'est occupé du dîner à table
elle fait connaissance avec la
famille tu
de
as une belle assiette là vous travaillez
du coup
[Musique]
Mamed vous faites
quoi je fais le
nettoyage la
planche là on vient pour en fait voir ce
que vous vous vivez au quotidien parce
que il y a pas de bon
hébergement dehors il y a pas de
logement
dehors
et moi c'est une nuit il y a des gens
pour qui c'est plusieurs semaines vous
ça fait depuis combien on a
dit 5
semaines Marie Charlotte Garin milite
pour une augmentation des places
d'ébergement d'urgence dans le projet de
loi de finan la députée avait déposé
deux amendements transpartisans soutenus
par la gauche le centre et la majorité
pour la création de 10000 places
supplémentaires
d'abord adopté en commission ils n'ont
pourtant pas pu être débattu pour cause
de 493 tout le chemin classique du
travail parlementaire moi je l'ai déjà
fait j'ai même gagné en théorie parce
que les amendements ils ont même été
votés mais comme on est dans une
démocratie défaillante il y a eu un coup
de 4 To et il y a pas eu mais les
interpellations mini je les ai faites
les communiqués de presse je les ai
faites les communications à d'autres
gûtés solidaires depuis un an que je
suis élu je les ai
faites et on se dit bah même quand on
essaie tout et même quand on gagne
finalement ça suffit
pas bah oui on va aller se
coucher
tuev l'hébergement d'urgence est un
dispositif coûteux 6 millions d'euros
sont déboursés par l'État chaque
jour face au besoins le gouvernement est
passé de 120000 places en 2017 à 200000
aujourd'hui et pourtant cela reste
insuffisant à l'aube nous retrouvons
Marie-Charlotte Garin et les
enfants j'ai pas eu froid j'étais
confortable mais j'ai beaucoup cogité
donc j'ai eu du mal à m'endormir et en
fait quand j'étais sur place tu obligé
de réfléchir à à toutes les conséquences
que ça a sur une vie de dormir ici et et
ça nourr encore plus la colère et
l'envie d'aller se battre
it bien
dormir ça ça
va au côté de la députée Juliette maman
et membre du collectif jamais sans toi
elle aussi aura dormi ici une condition
exigée par la mairie pour pouvoir
occuper
l'école dans quelques minutes toute
trace du passage de la famille aura
disparu et vous la journée vous faites
quoi du coup chaque jour il y a un
parent d'élèves qui accepté dans sa
maison faire
cuisiner cette famille peut compter sur
la solidarité des citoyens et des
associations locales en 9 an le
collectif de Juliette a mise à l'abri
enfants direction la permanence
parlementaire mariecharlotte Garin et la
bénévole font un tour d'horizon des
prochaines
actions ce qu'on fait là on fait
vraiment pas de guêé de cœur il y a pas
d'autrees option et personne d'autre ne
tend la main
donc les autorités se renvoient la balle
tant que personne réagit on est obligé
de faire comme ça et puisque nécessité
ne faittici àois l'année dernière 900
nuit solidaires ont été offertes 70000
en fait les parlementaires on est comme
une flèche et l'arc qui nous propulse
c'est la société civile donc c'est les
associations c'est la mobilisation
citoyenne et en gros on peut porter tout
ce qu'on veut si on n' pas justement ce
soutien en fait de la société civile et
des citoyens qui sont engagés pour faire
monter les sujets médiatiquement pour
les mettre à l'ordre du jour pour
rappeler leur importance bah en fait la
flèche elle tombe quoi alors qu'av avec
cet arc suffisamment puissant là on a
une chance d'atteindre notre cible une
cible loin d'être atteinte même si le
gouvernement a décidé de sauver un
amendement du groupe écologiste dans le
projet de loi de finances 6 millions
d'euros supplémentaires l'équivalent de
600 places d'hébergement d'urgence sur
la France
entière un combat qui se mène dans les
lignes budgétaires mais aussi sur le
terrain avec comme principe le système D
jamais sans toi s'est battu pour ouvrir
un un nouveau lieu d'hébergement
d'urgence dans cet épad laissé vacant
grâce à la mairie il accueille depuis
septembre ses premiers
occupantci moi ici ma fille là-bas et
mon enfant ici ils ont quel âge vos
enfants mon enfant il est autiste il a
10 ans ouis et la fille c'est elle a 8
ans là on est dans une ancienne chambre
d'étade exactement ça sent encore un
tout petit peu la la
naftaline c'est les petites odeurs qu'il
y a dans les é
rigol vous cette mère est partie du
Maroc pour une meilleure prise en charge
de son enfant autiste elle a dormi chez
des familles d'accueil dans des gymnases
a connu la rue aujourd'hui elle peut
souffler notre rôle finalement
aujourd'hui nous parlementaires mais
aussi les citoyens engagés les
collectifs les assauts bah c'est de
pouvoir porter votre voix parce qu'en
fait vous vous êtes trop occupé à à
survivre juste à penser où est-ce qu'on
va dormir demain comment je vais nourrir
mes enfants
bien s et vous avez pas le temps de
aussi vous battre pour défendre vos
propres droits bah du coup c'est à nous
de le faire c'est notre responsabilité
de défendre le droit des personnes qui
sont dans la rue et de leur dire mais en
fait c'est pas possible on peut pas
vivre dans un pays avec autant de
richesse que le nôtre aujourd'hui et
accepter qu'il y a des gens qui dorment
dehors on est bien soulagé à l'aise pas
de changement tout le temps parce que là
vous êtes là depuis septembre c'est ça
oui septembre
ou c'est propre c'est en sécurité
exactement c'est CH Oui bien sûr un
répit de courte durée puisque dans moins
d'un an elle devra quitter les lieux en
attendant sans ressources cette ancienne
comptable cherche un travail
ici pour être comptable ou bien un aide
comptable c'est difficile sans papiller
c'est trop trop difficile et on cherche
partout même le ménage même même ça vous
vous arrivez pas oui non vous avez envie
de pouvoir gagner votre
vie travailler avoir une activité vous
loger même des enfants il demandent
quelque chose
pas ou c'est dur oui c'est très
dur comme elle 35 personnes dont 21
enfants passeront l'hiver dans cet
hébergement
d'urgence Lyon comme d'autres grandes
métropoles a décidé d'attaquer l'État
pour carence dans la prise en charge des
personnes à la
rue dans son combat mariechlotte Garin
n'est pas seule à l'Assemblée une
vingtaine de parlementaires réfléchi
ensemble à de nouvelles formes de
mobilisation pour faire remonter la
cause dans les priorité du
[Musique]
gouvernement